all right yeah welcome back I'm hanging
out with my friend Seth Meyers Twitter
throws us some pretty big questions
alright y'all but fear not Seth and I
are here to give brilliant answers to
those questions and another round of
Kelly's Korn Twitter questionnaire
[Music]
here's how it works I'll read some of
the most thoughtful questions we found
on Twitter during the quarantine then
said that I will help out with some
answers okay it's like a different
version of Dear Abby here we go our
first on today's Twitter questionnaire
comes from at David Colucci I think
everyone is talking about good
quarantine habits tell me your worst I
for one have started chewing nicotine
gum for no reason other than it was on
sale at the pharmacy Oh your life David
because obviously not a lot is going on
what's your what's your worst chord do
you have it um I don't know I think I'm
over flossing just like break up the day
you know q-tips I already took Queen I
love cleaning my ears I can't stand I
can't stand like any kind of moisture in
my ears and I've been showering a lot
because we live on a ranch and I I'm
probably going to run my ears somehow
look I love a good q-tip but I like to
savor it I don't know I feel like over
using a q-tip takes away the excitement
for me it's a treat it's you know mind
if I accomplish something yourself a
q-tip yeah I do I love cleaning up my
ears okay can I ask you a q-tip question
do you yes do you do one q-tip that you
switched for each ear or just each ear
get one q-tip here's the weird thing
about me it's so interesting you asked I
do one q-tip and I do one side and then
I do the other side deep in and then I
take another q-tip and I do the at like
around you know inside here yeah same
thing with the other side
I swear yeah it's a process yeah I enjoy
q-tips
I call them orgasms they're good we may
want to not put that in the show org
I don't know he'll put it in
the next one is from at hello Cullen
what is Seinfeld met The Sopranos
that's actually great just like what
what happened yeah like what do you so
says what do you think turf or like I'm
just saying on them I think like Jerry
would be like I think it would be more
interesting to see Kramer with them
anyway I love sorry it was definitely
like sort of like blow up the mob game
somehow yes it would have been a great
episode um good question okay this next
one is from Jay portney who asks what's
the dumbest fight you've gotten into and
Quarantine well you know it here's the
thing you should never ask a married
person that's right yeah I don't even
know like brain and I I it's just
because it's every the kids are crazy
everything's crazy and all we're all
together I mean if you're you and your
wife have y'all just yeah yeah stupid
things where I'm staying well my am our
two-year-old like like fell and hit his
his a chin and you know he split it open
and I immediately panicked because I
thought were gonna have to go to history
which is obviously non place you want to
be right now you know because you don't
want to require the attention of first
responders who are dealing with more
important things and basically while I
was flipping out and screaming about how
bad it was my wife just like put a
bandaid on it became very clear that I'm
not the person you wanted to crisis
okay I'm you and my husband is her um
yeah I would've been like oh my god I
can't even there's not even we've had so
many dumb arguments like stupid and then
we and then literally in a moment we're
like this is so stupid like let's just
go over drink um the next one that was
supposed to buy at Laura wags I turned
27 this weekend what are people doing
for birthdays besides Tim calls well I
spent my alone because I know a lot of
people are in isolation and they don't
have people living in their house but I
have many people living in my house and
I wanted to be alone on my birthday and
it was beautiful what about you yeah
I mean guests like those like VR goggles
where I would just sit and like being
someone else yeah yeah I have those
they're so cool
my daughter loves to do the deep-sea one
it's so cool but no that's a good one
that's a good idea unless you don't have
you know a VR thing and then it just
looked like we were abroad you know it
also works as two toilet paper rolls and
you just hold your phone against it
alright last question in the corn
Twitter questionnaire I hate tuna
um comes from a tower Thomas Hoff 34
what a handle if you could be
quarantined with a superhero ooh who
would you pick and why also who would be
the worst superhero to be stuck with in
a house oh my gosh I'm feeling Wolverine
you don't any stuck with someone who has
you know claws just you know you know we
get angry fast so I'd say you don't you
don't want a Wolverine I mean you know
all things being equal I feel like
Batman it's pretty resourceful you know
has the most stuff on his belt whole
stuff yeah yeah so I think that that
would be my choice yeah honestly I was
gonna pick Batman as well but then I
thought flying would be fun it would
really be a way to get out of the house
so maybe I mean yeah but then I think
like a lot of people would be like you
gotta fly with a mask on because and I
feel like if the first time I fly don't
I like ruin it with that I think it's
funny the best part of your answer with
Wolverine is every female just disagreed
with you in my room with media that was
a good one all right well thank you so
much said it's always good to see you I
know that you're slammed with work we
all are right now we're trying to you
know keep everyone distracted and and
you know because it's kind of a scary on
certain time but everybody y'all can
watch late night was
- weeknights on NBC it's seriously one
of my favorite shows ever he's so great
y'all should watch it we will be right
back
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going